so five years ago I told you that I
would show you something if we ever
cross paths at a junket again so I have
a little clip for you to watch here it's
an awesome team I really like that but
before I go can I kind of made a joke of
it once and now it's stuck okay too big
no that's so perfect okay good okay
where is it it's it's right here I said
I would do it I do not lie is my hair
ready I adore that thing so so I said to
myself before I asked you if the
handwriting isn't nice or in two is not
written correctly I'm not gonna do it
and it's fine you you read it you wrote
it beautifully and now I have a tattoo
that I will have for the rest of my life
and love and I also love this movie so
so much good you've obviously done so
many Marvel movies at this point I was
wondering if you could go back in time
and give yourself one piece of advice
before jumping into your very first MCU
movie what would it be don't be anxious
relax and enjoy just this whirlwind blow
into this this whole wonderful process
here does anybody come up to you and ask
you for advice especially a first-timer
because I know you and Bree have worked
together on other projects before so did
anybody ever ask you what should I keep
in mind when I jump into the MCU no Bree
and I talked about it we had some
interesting conversations about it and I
told her you know it's interesting
responsibility to become that thing and
we had long conversations about losing
your anonymity and what the popularity
of those characters means in terms of
how people approach you and how people
look at you and everything's going to be
different and that was before I saw the
movie
so now that I've seen it it's even
bigger than I thought you know it's like
sure we have superheroes and people like
people like superheroes in the universe
but they never had anyone to attach to
the way I think women and girls will
attach to this particular character
because yes she's Captain Marvel but
before that she was Carol Danvers she
was somebody who had done something she
was somebody before they discovered her
and claimed that they made her what she
is so that when she's making the
discovery of her past
she's also realizing that wow I am
something that was special I was special
I could do something that not many
people could do that fly jet I could do
this I had accomplished all these things
I got knocked down ten times and I got
up in Louisville and every time I got up
I was a stronger better person and
that's a great message I have a best
friend who's also very special and we
support each other as women in this
thing that's a big guide thing and I
have a little girl who looks up at both
of us who's constantly reminding us that
you're my role models so make sure you
do the right thing and those aren't
messages that you normally find in these
movies that people come to constantly
say well there's too many of them and
it's just another thing with a lot of
noise and people and suppose it's crap
this movie is gonna change a lot of
different things and how people do me
wonder one moves great this is some
different I mean they're gonna be Jesus
she's gonna be on little girls walls
absolutely something different both are
fantastic and I'm just so excited that
this is a lasting change that's actually
happening so thank you so much for your
time
you